heute geht es jetzt um harry frank wird
diesen netten älteren her hier aber sie
werden entsetzt sein wenn sie erfahren
gleich was er für bücher geschrieben hat
er hat ein buch geschrieben das heißt so
darüber hat er ein buch geschrieben
genau genommen ist es gar kein buch
sondern es ist eigentlich nur ein essay
dieses buch ist sehr klein ich kann es
mal das nächste mal mit brille und
durchgehen lassen so groß und so kam
vielleicht so ein kleines format und die
schrift ist sehr sehr groß als es
eigentlich ein aufsatz der in buchform
erschienen ist man sehr sehr
lesenswertes kleines büchlein was sich
mit der frage beschäftigt was wahrheit
ist und frankfurt sagt bullshit ist also
eine besondere art der wahrheit des
wahrheit' entzugs als bullshit ist
letztendlich und indifferenz gegenüber
der wahrheit ist es nicht lüge weil lüge
wäre gerade nicht indifferenz gegenüber
der wahrheit weil die wahrheit der lüge
bewusst wahrgenommen wird bewusst
reflektiert wird und bewusst gegen die
wahrheit sich entschieden wird oder eine
aussage getätigt wird die gegen die
wahrheit gerichtet ist die nicht der
wahrheit entspricht was aber impliziert
dass man eben weiß was wahr ist während
bullshit nach frankfurt noch schlimmer
als die lüge ist weil bullshit gar keine
reflexion mehr darauf enthält was war
der falsch ist demjenigen harry
frankfurt nennt ihm diese person ein
bullshit
ein bursch etr dem ist die wahrheit
gänzlich egal wenn sich gleich und das
tag frankfurt ist noch viel schlimmer
als jemand erlösen kann jemand der gar
nichts auf die möglichkeit von wahrheit
gibt also sehr lesenswertes kleines
büchlein und wir wollen aber heute uns
mit zwei ganz zentralen aufsetzen
beschäftigen
und wir haben den auch ungeschickt
diesen aufsatz weil es ein bachelor
seminar ist haben sie diesen aufsatz auf
deutsch bekommen aber er ist natürlich
im englischen original schon viel früher
erschien als er es erst 2001 wirklich
gut ins deutsche übersetzt worden er sei
aber schon 30 jahre davor erschienen und
zwar in diesem jahr
sophie da war harry frankfurt habe ich
nach rechts erst 32 sehr gut für 32 so
einen aufsatz zu schreiben und diese
aufsatz ist ein klassiker und deswegen
lesen den auch in der heutigen sitzung
gemeinsam und wir lesen in unter
folgenden leitfragen wir haben jetzt
eine ganze reihe von fragen aufgelistet
dass sie die einfach auch mal so ein
bisschen im hinterkopf haben also
frankfurt kritisiert zu seiner zeit
anfang der 70er jahre gängige theorien
der person also wir wollen damit auch
immer den blick werfen auf benachbarte
gebiete die mit der willensfreiheit eng
zusammenhängt also willensfreiheit steht
nicht für sich diese sind zwar ein
riesen komplex wir haben das letzte mal
hier sagt einige begriffe angeschrieben
wir hätten da auch noch irgendwie den
begriff der person aufnehmen können die
hängt natürlich auch mit vince fall
zusammen also willensfreiheit schwebt
mich irgendwie der luft sind ist es
immer die frage wer oder was ist da
willens frei und das ist die frage nach
dem subjekt der freiheit oder auch nach
den fans oh wie versteht frankfurt die
person weil der titel wie sie sehen
neben freedom of the world and the
concept of person heißt also es ist
immer diese dopplung will zweiten person
dann diese ganz berühmte unterscheidung
zwischen koalitionen also wo löschens
erster ordnung und zweiter ordnung und
hier stellt sich natürlich gleich ein
problem wenn es mal überlegen wenn
willensfreiheit bedeutet von einer
höheren warte von volition zweiter
ordnung auf koalition erster ordnung zu
reflektieren stellt sich das problem
wieso soll ich denn auf der zweiten
ordnung bleiben wie sie sollen das das
ende science müsste ich nicht noch ein
ich von einer dritter ordnung die
koalition meine zweiter ordnung
reflektieren und so weiter von einer
vierten ordnung die der dritten das hat
auch gar kein ende
wo sollten bitteschön jetzt dann schluss
sein mit dieser reflexion und das ist
also ein regress problem könnte man
sagen oder so ähnliche hierarchie die
sich aufbläht und frankfurter auch eine
these zu diesem regress probleme
dann kann man sich fragen was gehört
nach frankfurt zum wesen einer person
und wie unterscheidet sich diese willen
zwei personen von tieren zb auch eine
frage ist was ein london ist das ist ein
trieb haffter die deutsche besetzung ist
ein triebhafte und das ist auch gar
nicht so klar was damit gemeint ist wir
wollen diesen begriff auch klären dann
kann man sich fragen die vernünftigkeit
personalität und willensfreiheit mit
einer zusammenhang also ist eine person
willensfreiheit die vernünftig ist ist
vernünftigkeit hinreichend für
willensfreiheit das ist eine ganz alte
debatte wie sie vielleicht wissen im
mittelalter gab es schon diese debatte
zwischen intellekt ua listen und wohl
und aris zu intellektuell listen sackten
willensfreiheit besteht in der vernunft
im befolgen desjenigen was die vernunft
vorgibt und wohl und touristen sagt nein
der wille der wille ist das
entscheidende nicht die vernunft und
diese debatte findet sich auch schon
wieder bei harry frankfurt in ansätzen
also wie verhalten sich vernünftigkeit
vernunft und wille
hinsichtlich der frage nach der freiheit
ja da kann man sich fragen wie er
willensfreiheit bestimmt im gegensatz zu
oder analogie zur handlungsfreiheit
hatten die letzten sitzung schon
diskutiert wie man das genau definieren
kann dann die ganz spannende frage
willkür thema der willkür oder der wahl
ist für harry frankfurt willensfreiheit
eine freiheit der wahl der alternativen
möglichkeiten
oder ist das prinzip der alternativen
möglichkeiten was wir immer mit php
abkürzen p
ist es eigentlich irrelevant oder sogar
falsch in einem weiteren aufsatzes wird
harry frankfurts sagen es ist fallen für
das wort sagt er so wörtlich das ist
eine frage und dann kann man sich fragen
wenn jetzt alternative möglichkeiten
nicht so wichtig sind oder sogar falsch
sind dieses prinzip wer bestellt wird
sie verhalten sich dann willens weit und
determinismus zusammen sind sie
miteinander vereinbar
und wie begründet er diese auffassung
dass sie vereinbar sind wohl dieses
prinzip nicht berücksichtigt werden muss
dass die spannende frage
das sind glaube ich jetzt unsere
hauptfragen für die heutige sitzung sie
können sich wie gesagt die folien jetzt
herunterladen wenn sie auf die lowcost
punkte gehen und den neuesten eintrag
sich an schon haben sie genau diese
folien jetzt auch vorsicht wenn man das
jetzt nicht so gut lesen kann wegen der
sonnen gut
dann beginnen wir doch einfach mal mit
dem aufsatz wir machen das immer so dass
wir die für uns wichtigsten zitate hier
an auf die folien kopieren und dann
hierhin projizieren und dann einfach
gemeinsam lesen und dann über diese
zitate diskutieren er fängt mit einem
zitat anders lautet folgendermaßen was
unter philosophen neuerdings als analyse
des begriffs app person angesehen wird
ist in wirklichkeit gar keine analyse
dieses begriffs schossen das ist also
ein bekannter philosoph dieser zeit
dessen wort gebraucht zum gängigen
standard geworden ist bestimmten begriff
eine person als zitat den begriff eines
tipps von entitäten derart dass sowohl
prädikate die bewusstseinszustände zu
schreiben als auch prädikat die körper
eigenschaften bezeichnen auf ein
einzelnes individuum dieses besonderen
tipps gleichermaßen anwendbar sind
das ist also nachts geschlossen eine
person
so eine person person gleich individuum
könnte man sagen marco wir machens
individuum wollen wir das am besten
veranschaulichen ein individuum ist eine
person und das hat es so sagen zwei
eigenschaften auf das können wir zwei
prediger klassen von prädikaten
gleichermaßen anwenden also hier wäre
das eben prädikate die
bewusstseinszustände beschreiben als
auch körper eigenschaft als man könnte
sagen mentale prädikat und für physische
oder physikalischen oder körperlich so
und das ist jetzt frankfurt nicht
befriedigen und jetzt können sie sich
mal überlegen warum warum können wir
eine person nicht so angemessen
beschreiben dass wir sagen es ist ein
individuum was sowohl mentale die
physikalische prädikate reduziert
bekommen kann
verlegen sie mal
wenn sie schon ein bisschen weiter
gelesen haben wissen sie es schon bei
frankfurt gleich im nächsten zitat das
jetzt kritisiert ich glaube wir können
das fenster wieder zu machen überlegen
sie mal warum ist das nicht angemessen
um eine person zu beschreiben
genau genau zumindest nicht alle tiere
also man könnte sich jetzt die frage
stellen sind wir als personen auch tiere
gibt es personale tiere also wir sind
natürlich auch irgendwie organisch
verfasst wir teilen sehr sehr viel auch
vom feind unserer dna mit mit schweinen
und ratten und so also wir haben schon
sehr viel tierische anteil in uns aber
die frage ist einfach das genügt es sind
ist das nicht eine zu weite definition
mitunter fallen offensichtlich wesen
entitäten lebewesen darunter von denen
wir definitiv sagen würden sie sind
nicht personen
sie haben sich jetzt gerade gemeldet und
tier genannt was könnte denn ein tier
für mentale prädikate zugeschrieben
bekommen zum beispiel haben sie eine
idee ja also das man einfach mentale
prädikate auch oft hier was ein mentales
prädikat kann ich denn konkret ist man
einem tier zum beispiel zu schreiben
ja das 10
ja instinkt ist jetzt noch ein bisschen
marcoussis instinkt ist wäre das ein
mentales prädikat
aber man kann es fing schon so verstehen
dass wenn man etwas instinktiv macht das
ist da aber es muss nicht unbedingt
implizieren dass man dieses ist in
diesen räumen muss vielleicht gibt es
noch immer warten sie noch die ja
durchaus auch also im sinne von
kognition wenn man jetzt sagt das tier
hat zb so eine instrumentelle
intelligenz manifestiert an zum beispiel
creme creme können instrumentelle
schlüsse ziehen
sie wissen also wenn ich die nuss auf
die straße fallen lasse und dann fährt
ein autor über und deswegen lassen sie
die runterfallen das ist also dieses
phänomen aber das wird sich sonst alten
mentales prädikat was man direkt zu
schreibt das ist er sein disposition
also vermögen oder so ja aber ja furcht
genau würde ich sagen oder so ein
emotionaler zustand
das hatten sie ja auch schon ins spiel
gebracht so eine quasi also quark war
also ein bewusstseinszustand wie zustand
zum bruder marco und ist natürlich nicht
und es gibt gründe weise die partie sie
aner und in cannes selbst bezeichnen
dass tiere überhaupt bewusst selbst
gestellt hat sie genau wer eben sagen
würde die funktionieren ganz so manche
maschinen könnten ihre musikalische
eigenschaft wenn wir nehmen's mentale
eigenschaften zuschreiben
es ist dann machen wir damit ein andere
profis muss oder werden würde
man muss zur fähre hat dazu sagen als
ich hatte im letzten semester seminare
geben über den geiste tiere und die card
also hast es auch richtig völlig richtig
wiedergeben die karts sagt nicht dass
tiere kein geist haben also macht keine
unter logische aussagen sondern sagt
ihren videos auch gesagt dass wir können
es nicht wissen ob beziehungsweise hat
er einen sohn methodologischen ansatz er
sagt es ist am vernünftigsten ökologisch
sparsamsten aufgrund unserer
phänomenalen ausgangslage tieren nicht
so was wie mentale prädikat
zuzuschreiben sondern es reicht völlig
aus das ganze verhalten von tieren
mechanistisch also physikalisch zu
beschreiten
also das ist dieser unterschied er sagt
nicht direkt sie sind maschinen sind
sagt wir verstehen sie am besten wir
sollten sie verstehen als maschinen weil
alles andere völlig unnötig ist dann
noch was zusätzliches postulieren ist
genügt völlig sie zu bestehen
verstehen aber das ist diese karte
sische position und wie du glaub ich
völlig richtig sagst vertritt heutzutage
eigentlich niemand mehr nicht
sonst eine idee von mentalen zustand
eines tieres als emotionale zustände von
tatsächlich wie sie schon sagten also
auch wir finden durchaus bei höheren
tierarten intelligenz und und
instrumentelle rationalität wie eben bei
krähen und raben die sind also wirklich
sehr sehr intelligent sehr beeindruckend
also das ist sie sehen also er
kritisiert jetzt horsens auffassung der
person ist zu weit da fallen individuen
runde unter diese definition die beiden
also eigenschaften anspruch
anforderungen genügen aber die wir nicht
als person bezeichnen würden meint ihr
was in einem mental einen mentalen
zustand der furcht hat oder der der
angst hat oder was auch immer
das ist keine person dadurch schon als
wir müssen sozusagen das ist die
stoßrichtung wir müssen das mentale hier
ein bisschen weiter analysieren also
hier müssen wir ansetzen
das mentale als solches gibt noch nicht
wir müssen ein spezialfall von mentalen
prädikaten oder mentalen eigenschaften
analysieren um auf die person zu stoßen
tja das und jetzt kommt die antwort also
nun gibt es jedoch neben personen- noch
viele andere entitäten die sowohl
mentale wie physische eigenschaften
haben nämlich tiere manche tiere oder
eigentlich alle tieren auch wenn es
merkwürdig sein mag aber es ist nun
einmal so dass es kein gebräuchliches
englisches oder deutsches wort für die
art von entitäten gibt dies trossen sich
denkt entitäten zu denen außer menschen
genauso auch tiere verschiedene niedrige
raten gehören
doch rechtfertigt dieser umstand
natürlich nicht den missbrauch eines
wichtigen und wertvollen philosophischen
terms missbraucht wir sollten ihnen nur
reservieren für also individuen die in
diesem sehr engen und ausgezeichneten
sinne person genannt werden können weil
person auch ein normativer begriff ist
würde ich sagen oder also mit wenn wir
sagen das ist eine person dann
unterstellen wir dass sie zb zurechenbar
ist für ihre handlungen dass sie
trägerin von zuschreibung sein kann
objekt von zuschreibungen wie schuld wir
aber auch wie lob und so weiter die wir
von der ewe etwas fordern können als
person die wir auf eine besondere weise
behandeln müssen diese was wie eine
würde hat zum beispiel das würde diesen
es auch so ein begriff war so ein
synonym für personen sind wesentlich
eine würde haben
und nein dazu fänden es noch ein also da
kannst du wieder und weise noch person
theorien einschlagen es gab auch die
maschine wieder glücklich leben
ich weiß dass julian hintersinn erleben
wir warten mal hier hat ein fahrzeug
gehalt rettungs und so erging es gerade
um diese normative grenze wo man den
sogenannten und ich glaub ich glaube sie
würde jetzt nicht unbedingt sich auf den
begriff festlegen aber die völlig ich
schon sagen dass entscheidende grenze
ist dort ebenso was im bewusstsein haben
und mit allgemeinen system würde sie es
viel weiter passen
das müssen man unserem deutschen recht
genau den will sie braucht und was genau
steht der rechte ist gemacht
also du sagst völlig richtig es gibt
vertreterinnen und vertreter der
philosophie die sagen wir müssen die
diese diese hürde gar nicht so hoch
setzen sondern es genügt tatsächlich
dass wir zum innenleben haben sind
bewusst ist also phänomenales bewusst
sein selbstbewusstsein muss gar nicht
erfüllt sein dass des tieres lebewesen
ich weiß was es denkt oder so dass
zweiter ordnung von reflexionen hat
sondern es genügt dass ein lebewesen
einfach empfindungsfähigkeit und
irgendwas registrieren kann
und da sagt martin nida rümelin das ist
fertig entscheidende grenze für
normativität ob ein tier bewusstsein hat
phänomenal das bewusstsein ein lebewesen
und nicht ob es noch irgendwelche
vernünftigen momente hat oder second
ordervolumens oder so das sagt sie das
ist schon viel zu viel gefordert wir
setzen die hürde bis sie niedriger an
kann natürlich auch machen
das ist dann so eine position die eben
auch häufig der tierschutz großer den
tierschutz sehr stark macht aber es
heißt natürlich auch nicht dass wenn wir
personen jetzt zu erfassen und im
mentalen bestimmte fähigkeiten aufweisen
müssen dass wir dann schließen können
dass wir lebewesen die nicht diesen
engere diese engeren definition von
personen genügend das wird die einfach
also indifferent behandeln dürften also
was folgt daraus nicht mehr die tatsache
dass ein individuum keine person ist ein
lebewesen keine person ist heißt nicht
dass es nicht auch gewisse rechte
besitzt oder das ist auf eine bestimmte
weise behandelt werden sollte finde ich
nicht dass das daraus folgt anhalt nicht
in so einem exklusiven sinn aber und im
abgeleiteten sind kann man das durchaus
auch genau ist es auch genau obwohl hier
keine person status hat ist das verboten
manche philosophen immanuel kant haben
das so begründet dass sie gesagt haben
wir sollten nicht deswegen tier nicht
wählen weil es den tieren so schlecht
aber er geht sondern weil das unsere
moralität verdirbt also er hat es auch
wieder von der person ausgedacht jemand
der tiere quält der wird moralisch
korrumpiert und dessen moral leidet
darunter
ja ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu sehr
subjekt zentriert aber ich denke dass
das nicht raus folgt ja okay und jetzt
kommt die generelle these jetzt kommt so
diese frage die antwort auf die frage
was ist dann dieses mentale im engeren
sinne was individuen zur person macht
und dass jetzt die antwort darauf dass
so die perspektive des ganzen auf satz
sagt ich bin der ansicht dass ein
wesentlicher unterschied zwischen
personen und anderen kreaturen in der
struktur des willens einer person zu
finden ist
menschen sind nicht die einzigen wesen
die wünsche und motive haben oder die
welt wahl entscheidungen treffen sie
unterscheiden sich darin nicht von
mitgliedern anderer arten von denen
einige anscheinend sogar erwägungen
anstellen und entscheidungen nach
vorhergehender überlegung treffen wie
zum beispiel krähen das oder delfin
solche tiere können dass es scheint aber
eine besondere eigenständigkeit von
menschen zu sein dass sie wie ich sie
nennen werde wünsche zweiter stufe zu
bilden fähig sind
also hier kommt jetzt diese berühmte
second order theorie und spiel und wir
lesen gartner weiter
neben wirtschaft wird 80 das ist
menschen eigentlich ist es da waren und
milde und ganzen
musste
bewusst sind jetzt in diesem text oder
das mentale hier also bewusstsein
generell okay also bewusst sein kann man
eben unterscheiden
ich mach das mal kurz hier ausland haben
wir können wir können zwischen
bewusstsein und selbstbewusstsein
unterscheiden und bewusstsein bloßen
sinne ist häufig wird häufig auch
phänomenales bewusstsein genannt
phänomenales bewusstsein bedeutet dass
man so etwas wie ein wie zustand eine
empfindung hat eine subjektive
empfindung haben kann also
schmerzempfinden ist zum beispiel ein
fall von phänomenale bewusstsein also
immer psychische ereignisse wahrnehmen
kann wahrnehme qualia also dass das wort
qualia ist hier so quali er kommt von
lateinisch quale und bedeutet wie
beschaffen sind also wie zustimmen wie
es ist etwas zu sein wie es ist
zahnschmerzen zu haben also
zahnschmerzen als zahnschmerzen
empfinden zu können und das bewusst
empfinden zu können
also ich bin mit dessen also dann darf
es dann schon an
wir wussten wann es selbstbewusstsein
aber als einfach 1 1 wie zustand in sich
zu haben
noch immer auf sich warten nicht leicht
also ich doch zu unserem unterschied auf
denen wir aufmerksam mache welche
irgendwie sagen dass es irgendwie ist
etwas das ich irgendwie ahnt wie eine
fledermaus zu sagen vielleicht sogar
schon eine fliege zu sein
aber im unterschied dazu würden wir
nicht sagen es ist irgendwie das fühlt
sich irgendwie an einen stand zu sein
also da ist irgendwie noch mal ein
unterschied wie man es leicht in die
hilfe des phänomenalen los 1
oder dass es irgendwie ist so sein
fassen kann und das kann man noch mal
eben so schön selbstbewusst und heftig
typ ist genau das problem ist wenn wir
jetzt über selbstbewusster über
phänomenales bewusstsein reden sind wir
einig schon auf der ebene des
selbstbewusstseins
also wir jetzt ist eine fledermaus zu
sein das ist keine frage des
phänomenalen bewusstseins sonders
selbstbewusstseins würde ich sage also
das ist ein riesenproblem weil sobald
wir über phänomenales bewusstsein reden
wir schon auf einer höheren ebene sind
der selbstbewusstseins ebene natürlich
reflektiert die fledermaus nicht wie es
ist eine fledermaus sein
sie geht darin ganz auf wir die wir
darüber sprechen oder die wir auch über
qualia sprechen sprechen deswegen über
quali oder können deswegen immer quali
entsprechen weil wir selbstbewusstsein
verfügen als ein riesenproblem mir dass
wir in dem wir darüber reden eigentlich
hier schon drin sein selbstbewusstsein
selbstbewusstsein bedeutet einfach die
eigenen das eigene phänomenale
bewusstsein oder antritt innere zustände
wiederum im modus eines inneren zustand
zu repräsentieren oder zu reflektieren
es sei also ich habe jetzt dies die bin
in dieser stimmung und ich verhalte mich
so vielleicht mit einer anderen stimmung
zu dieser stimmen jetzt irgendwie
traurig und das reflektiere ich und ich
reagiere so auf diese traurigkeit ich
schließe daraus ich ziehe daraus
schlüsse das ist dann selbstbewusstsein
oder auch dass ich eben ja ich bin mir
dessen bewusst dass ich jetzt hier
diesem moment in dieser stimmung mich
befinde
also selbstbewusstsein ist eben dann
auch sonst wie subjektiv
die die sich selbst erkennt das ist also
ein riesenfeld auch noch mal für sich da
könnte man auch ein riesengroßes seminar
wieder darüber geben über
selbstbewusstsein das einfach die
reflexion von mentalen phänomen die sich
in einem selbst als objekt finden
nein geht er nicht ein
volk hat genau also könnte man sich
fragen was man ihr selbstbewusstsein
oder subjektivität theorie liegt dem
zugrunde hat keine ausgearbeitete
subjektivität these wenn es wenn ich
mich nicht irre da ist er thomas nagel
dieser philosophie der hat da mehr
gesagt über subjektivität und selbstlos
sein wenn sie einen großen bedeutenden
münchner philosophen namentlich genannt
bekommen wollen der sich sehr viele
gedanken zum thema selbstbewusstsein
gemacht hat der lebt auch noch dann ist
das der dieter henrich
es ist vielleicht der bedeutendste
denker von selbstbewusstsein der
gegenwart der noch lebt der hat ganz
viel über selbstbewusst gemacht auch im
anfang an die klassische deutsche
philosophie also deutschen idealismus
immanuel kant und vor allem fichte und
auch regel auch ein bisschen schilling
da ist also dieter henrich der experte
historisch
ja
zum beispiel die beispiele in frankfurt
mit also lieber nicht auf ein
nein
genau also zum beispiel das betrifft
dann letztendlich die handlungsfreiheit
wir kommen dann noch kaufen also wenn
ich etwas in mir habe aber mich nicht
richtig aktiv dazu verhalten also mir
wird jetzt auch durchaus bewusst dass
diese trennung scheint es zu marco du
kannst sagen was du davon hält dass
diese trennung zwischen phänomenalen
bewusstsein und selbstbewusstsein nicht
so eindeutig ist wie man es häufig tut
weil dieser wie zustand wie es ist etwas
zu sein
der treibt ich glaube das haben sie
richtig bemerkt er treibt über sich
hinaus also wenn er nur stark genug ist
werden wir vielleicht fast zum
selbstbewusstsein gedrängt dass wir
darüber dann noch mal wirklich
reflexionen anstellen dass wir nicht
einfach nur diesen zustand aufgehen das
vlies es kommt mir jetzt auch so ein
bisschen als freund die unterscheidung
fast gar nicht so ganz stichhaltig es
gibt dann bei den phänomenologie um
dieses thema dann auch zu ende zu
bringen gibt es dann eine theorie die
sagt wenn ich jetzt hier ein mentale
qualität habe nehme ich sie mal eben 1
dann ist die dass selbst wird es jetzt
ein phänomenaler zustand dann ist das
selbstbewusstsein davon nicht so was wie
m2 was ich darauf was was sozusagen
separat davon existiert und sich darauf
bezieht das wäre so eine vorstellung von
selbstbewusstsein so dass es ihr so was
sagen jedenfalls die phänomenologie es
ist sowas dass es dasselbe ist was sich
also eine interne eingeschriebene
selbstbezüglichkeit hat das ist eine
qualität des mentalen dass es auf sich
selbst sich bezieht macht christopher er
unser kollege immer sehr stark aus der
phänomenologischen perspektive als
selbstbewusstsein ist ein ganz riesen
großes thema und wir wollten sie jetzt
hier mal kurz an sprechen es geht auch
harry frankfurt nicht so sehr um jetzt
die subjektivität im engeren sinne ist
es geht ihm um volition
um das wollen aber das verhält sich
natürlich ganz ähnlich weil es eine
mentale eigenschaft ist wie die
subjektivität und diese wünsche zweiter
stufe das ist jetzt sozusagen der
ansatzpunkt wobei damit wir noch nicht
mehr willensfreiheit gleich sind jetzt
sagte freundes neben wünschen und wählen
und bewegt werden dies oder das zu tun
können menschen außerdem wünschen
bestimmte wünsche oder motive zu haben
oder nicht zu haben
sie können was ihre vorlieben und zwecke
angeht gern anders sein wollen als sie
sind viele tiere scheinen durchaus so
wie ich sagen will wünschen erster stufe
fähig zu sein
kein tier außerdem menschen scheint
dagegen die fähigkeit zu reflektierenden
selbstbewertung zu haben die sich in der
bildung von wünschen zweiter stufe
ausdrücken hier ist ganz interessant
dass er sagt kein tier außerdem menschen
bis der mensch damit auch ein tier und
besondere art von tieren scheint so fast
ein bisschen impliziert zu sein das ja
der mensch ist auch ein tier aber es ist
halt ein personal ist ihr aber das ist
wiederum ein anderes thema das ist das
thema des sogenannten animalis muss das
ist eine gegenwärtige theorie und der
philosophie des geistes themen die
auffassung vertritt dass wir als
personen was unsere identität und
existenz bedingungen gelang wesentlich
tiere sind als an unseren biologischen
organismus gebunden sind
darin besteht unsere identität und nicht
zb in so etwas wie selbstbewusstsein was
nicht physikalisch jetzt und logisch
angemessen beschrieben werden kann
also hier ist das entscheidende bildung
von wünschen zweiter stufe
ihre reflexionen damals
selbstbewusstsein
und jetzt kann man vielleicht
weiter lesen weil er jetzt den begriff
des willens ins spiel bringt oder marco
willst du noch eine bemerkung machen zu
diesem september können wir mal
überlegen fließen
da werde ich schon sagen dass mit
politischen gemeinde nicht besonders
viele infiziert ist das ist noch ein
sehr effektiv ist also ich kann dinge
wünschen von denen ich gern ich weiß ich
kann wünsche haben wenn nicht gar nicht
bei uns irgendwelche versteckten
wünschen und in russland hat und ich
kann zum beispiel
wir wünschen ein treuer ehemann zu sein
aber in einer bestimmten situation dann
trotzdem etwas ganz anderes wollen also
es kann sein dass es auch zum stimmen
konflikt in hand wünsche kommt und das
wird am ende wohl ich den starken wunsch
draußen bleiben dann trotzdem etwas
anderes tun vielleicht auch weniger
absichtlich und woher dieser wunsch
weiter bestehen das ist vielleicht nur
so ein abstrakter wunsch den ich am ende
dann auch fahren
ich bin jetzt im management
wie wichtig ihm die hübsche zweiter
stufe es kann in wünschen sich einen
bestimmten punkt der mich vielleicht gar
nicht also kann sein dass sich ein
völlig gefühllos kaltern endspiele wird
es immer vorgeworfen und dann sehe ich
irgend etwas ganz schreckliches und ich
würde mir wünschen den wunsch zu
verspüren diesen menschen zu helfen
aber es hat sich also bisher dann so
einen komischen seite stehen und das
muss man eben unterscheiden von einem
film oder von einer position zweiter
schlug
das ist ja so ein bisschen mit
beispielen
weil ich ganz guter abend zu brauchen
und wir haben auch schon das ist
ungesund ist
das ist ob sie gleich zum besten stehen
was ich dazu ist nicht zu ersetzen ist
keine vielleicht war das erste beispiel
ist damit die gleise auf der einen seite
meinen sinnen komisch zu rauchen
auf einigen situationen das durch
bemerkt auf der anderen seite meinte der
wunsch zweites und will nicht zu rauchen
also wunsch zweite stunde würde bedeuten
dass dieser wunsch also auf einen wunsch
nicht weg
stattdessen wünschen also zum beispiel
mit dem wunsch den wunsch zu brauchen
nicht mehr zu haben
plötzlich einfach so machen sie ist okay
und dann also man sieht ist
unterscheidet sich dann von dem tier mit
seiner scheiße brief und nach so okay er
ist enorm einklang mit fremden dass es
weitere möbel denke ich sagen dass tiere
auch als ich glaube zwei personen gute
frage also ich glaube dass oder wollen
sie gerade was dazu sagen ja
[Musik]
selbst ein kind das wir gebraucht die
längsten gibt ist schlecht für mich
dann überlegte er überall diesem grund
stellt der hund tut dass sich dieses
mal.mehr
auch nicht gebraucht wird
gut dann der punkt wenn wenn wenn sie
sagen konditioniert werden oder es aus
einem zwang heraus täten also dieses
nicht rauchen wollen oder aus angst oder
irgendwie solchen zuständen dann wäre es
wohl nach frankfurt wenn ich es recht
verstehe auch keine koalition zweiter
stufe sondern hätten sie ihr zwei
konflikt ihren koalition erster stufe
und dann würde sich die stärkere
position durchziehen durch durch sätze
zu sagen sie haben also 21 gleich
rauchen rauchen wollen brauchen die die
koalition zu rauchen und v2 wäre nicht
rauchen dann der wunsch der wurde jetzt
ja gut kann man dem wunsch genau wie
einst haben dann ist immer die frage wie
auf welcher ebene sind die angesiedelt
und so wie sie es beschreiben wären
jetzt die diese wünsche auf derselben
ebene angesiedelt sie wären letztendlich
nicht reflexiv gewonnen sondern sie
werden
irgendwie ja ich weiss nicht zwanghaft
oder will jetzt ja gar nicht konkret
sagen oder sozial indiziert sozial
zwanghaft induziert oder zum beispiel
dass man angst hat wegen wir
sanktioniert zu werden also erfurcht vor
irgendwie zuwiderhandlung oder so und
diesem fall würde ich das auch nicht
willens stufen oder wünsche zweite stufe
nennen seine erste stufe und beim hund
ist es ja ganz klar des beispiels gut
gewählt jetzt vor dem fressnapf vergibt
zum beispiel dann diese situation die
man sich ganz konkret vorstellen kann
der hund sieht da gibt's was zu fressen
kommt zu diesen apfel oder anders gesagt
der hund zieht auf dem küchengerät eine
wurst liegen oder brach sonntagsbraten
und der hund hat den wunsch dass zu
fressen und dann kommt aber plötzlich so
ein andrea wunsch oder so eine art
revolution rein dies die ihm sagt sagen
du liebe güte ich habe das schon mal
gemacht
wer so in erinnerung und damals wurde
ich dann als bisher bestraft dadurch war
weil ich das getan habe und dann würde
ich sagen dass das zwei konfigurieren de
wünsche oder mentale phänomene auf
derselben stufe sind wo sie die stärkere
durchsetzt was anderes wäre es zb jetzt
etwas zu essen etwas nicht zu essen ein
gericht nicht zu essen weil man zb damit
in einem abwägungsprozess dazu gekommen
ist dass wir besser nicht fleisch essen
sollten weil das eben dem prinzip des
vegetarismus widerspricht und weil
vegetarismus der eigenen überzeugung
nach wahr ist oder sinnvoll ist
ich glaube dass es ein prinzipieller
andere reflexion ist dass ich also dass
das die wurst nicht essen weil ich
vegetarier bin und weil ich bestimmte
moralische überzeugung mit dieser
position verbinden
das scheint mir dann eher auf eine
zweite stufe angelehnt angelegt
angesiedelt zu sein als dieses beispiel
ich es deswegen die wurst nicht weil ich
dann irgendwie gestraft werden oder so
dass einfach die frage wie viel
reflexion auch wie viele normative
überzeugungen damit rein kommen auch wie
vermittelbarkeit und unmittelbar karten
reinkommen und dem beispiel des hundes
wären das unmittelbar uns net c zitieren
oder uns in krien ihren de willens
regungen in uns und da würde sich die
stärkere einfach durchsetzen will jetzt
meine theorie
wir hatten mehrere meldungen ganz hinten
war noch eine und dann hier bzw sc vorne
und dann hinten ja
jeweils
das gerade behaupten dass gewinnen und
zu erhalten
frage ist aber wie das konnten
stabilisiert worden die in hand des
turniers beweisen dass ist habe ich die
plakette
das ist ein spannendes eine spannende
frage
es geht ja letztendlich auch so weit
dass wir letztendlich tieren alle
möglichen mentalen prädikate
unterstellen könnten aber da bin ich der
meinung dass das die beweispflicht
anders gelagert ist aber so ein riesen
debatte ich bin der meinung dass wir
nicht wirklich
indizien dafür haben dass hier eine
höhere stufe reflexion vorliegt das wird
dann eher sparsam umgehen sollten mit
der unterstellung von hör stufigen
entitäten es geht ja munter logischer
sparsamkeit wenn ich sowas wie willen
willens tendenzen zweiter stufe
postulieren
dann habe ich eine neue und theologie im
gegensatz zur position erster stumpfe
und ich bin der überzeugung dass wir mit
der postulieren von neuen entitäten also
uns sehr zurückhaltend also das wäre
zurückhaltend agieren sollten und
erstmal überlegen sollten könnten wir
nicht alles verhalten auf diese
einfachen stufe erster ordnung
beschreiben und wenn es dann fälle gibt
wo wir mit dieser erklärung aufgrund von
empirischen befunden nicht mehr zurecht
kommen dann haben wir ein grund andere
entitäten zu fordern aber nicht einfach
weil es möglich werden das scheint mir
einfach so den sieg der ontologischen
sparsamkeit
sitzen zu kriegen kann also zwischen
spaß und da geht es einfach darum dass
man nur soviel entitäten annimmt wie
möglich wenn man dieses prinzip nicht
akzeptiert dann kommt man schnell in
teufels küche weil man dann mit dass man
zum beispiel stellen wir uns vor unser
nachbar glaubt dass der weihnachtsmann
existiert immer merkt schnell dass man
ohne seien im prinzip eigentlich wenig
in dem entgegenzusetzen hat oder auch
jetzt wenn wir ein bisschen im falle von
koalitionen annehmen wenn sich im
gestein bewegt genauso wenn wir dieses
prinzip nicht hätten dann könnten wir an
dem einfach bestimmte dienste zu
schreiben stein fast dann ziemlich
schnell zum automobil führt wo wir dann
natürlich allen irgendwelche
irgendwelche mini und entscheidungen und
lebensweisen deswegen ist es prinzipiell
erst mal sinnvoll und damit man
natürlich aber offen sein ist der welt
mir ganz viele experimente an tieren
gemacht
dass man eben schaut was können sie für
aufgaben lösen unsere meinung nach muss
man eben vielleicht auch die tiere nicht
alle in einen topf werfen japan werfen
sondern auch ganz gut unterscheiden uns
vielleicht helfen wir gefunden
vielleicht höhere stufe genau also
prinzipiell ist eine logische frage
aber natürlich haben sie recht diese
unter logische frage hängt im falle von
tieren auch mit normativen fragen
zusammen also die frage ob jetzt wie ein
tier volition zweiter stufe zu schreiben
hat auswirkung auf die art und weise wie
wir mit dem umgehen müssen oder sollten
deswegen ist die frage nicht trivial
nicht nur eine theoretische spieler
reisen sie hat konkrete praktische
integration zumindest okay ja jetzt hat
nur noch eine meldung ganze
ab und zu kommen eigens darauf sein dass
es
man spart also entscheidend ist eben
klar wir auch das wort der bildung also
ein so ein wunsch zweiter stufe der muss
gebildet werden erst das heißt er darf
nicht irgendwie einfach nur so induziert
werden sondern der muss sich erarbeitet
werden da muss reflexion stattgefunden
haben und zwar nicht auf diese
unmittelbare weise also ich glaube dass
das ein kriterium ist bildung es muss
dann prozess stattgefunden habe
ja
das problem ist dass man sehr schnell so
cool er wird weil wenn man sagt bilden
dann würde man sagen ja was ist die
bildung im gegensatz zu ihrem beispiel
die bildung aus freiheit ja aber die
bildung ist sollte auch erst die
freiheit erklären
also wir können sind wir sehr schnell
dabei dass freiheit schon zu
unterstellen ist ein bisschen der
bildung
also ich bin auch eher kritisch was im
film zwei gibt es deswegen nicht gehört
trotzdem würde ich noch zwei
das müsste eine sache betonen das erste
ist frankfurt überhaupt wird nicht dass
der mensch immer egal was das heißt
irgendwie zu finden vielleicht mit dem
bau erwerben
leipzig
china hat in denen behauptet wird das
rauchen tipps zugesagt und so weiter
sondern der es einfach so viele menschen
im pool des rates sein leben lage so ein
medium vom kindesalter an uns das leben
einfach so über wind und daraus ergeben
sich irgendwie mit notwendigkeit seine
wünsche frei hätten versagt den fall ist
ein seit jahren fall also das wäre so
ein punkt also irgendwann auch wenn ich
dass wir menschen immer auf einer
monetären sondern er sagt vielleicht
sogar menschlich und ganz selten york
seien für das sagen will aber wissen
wichtiger punkt um ihn zu widerlegen
reicht das nicht das wäre ein leisten
und konstruieren in die man menschen
frei ist sondern wir müssen generell
gründe angeben dafür anzunehmen dass
menschen live im ersten widerlegen und
der zweite punkt ist nur weil wir etwas
gelernt haben ist oder ist uns klar dass
wir das irgendwann der schulung oder für
mich gesellschaft übernommen hat
das allein ist noch kein grund daraus zu
schließen dass das unser verhalten des
daraus resultiert nicht frei ist so
lucky wir annehmen dass wir die
fähigkeit haben es auch kritisch
hinterfragt
also manchmal also vielleicht nicht
immer manchmal
die gesellschaft auch ganz ungelegen vor
und wir können es hinterfragen können
erkennt nun das ist mein vater gesagt
hat bestimmt und dann können wir auch
bei hat diese sache tun unser genaueres
unserem vater gesagt hat oder die
gesellschaft die lehrer können oder was
immer das obwohl die werden gesagt aber
gefragt weil die fähigkeit als kritisch
hinterfragt schwierig wird es dann wenn
wie diese fähigkeit nicht mehr halten
also wenn wir vielleicht auch so erzogen
worden sind dass das wird sich mit der
frage was mir auch mal die meinungen der
gesellschaft und der anderen ein
klammern und uns war einfach ist es wenn
wir das nicht machen dann nämlich eher
auf jeder seite dass man sagt okay dann
wird es wirklich problematisch gekommen
uns persönlich sind sie dann nicht doch
mal ein fast ein bisschen wie beim und
einsprachen prinzipiell ja nicht ich bin
fest davon überzeugt dass gute
fähigkeiten kritisch hinterfragt was uns
geben wird vom gesellschafter von
anderen äußeren einflüssen
solange das annehmen ich denke ich ist
es die tatsache dass es um jemand
anderes zu vernommen haben und mittel um
zu zeigen dass wir ganz ruhig treibt es
ist das schweigen
aber dagegen dass ganz platzieren oder
auch das gericht wird er auch alle von
hier dass
ist es dann nicht um politische sondern
sinnvoll hier ein kantiger seien es sich
also wichtig ist ist keine rolle und
nachgeschichte keine alles oder nichts
dafür sondern wie ich bin vielleicht im
hinblick auf bestimmte handlungen oder
verhaltensmuster von mir freiem himmel
nicht
und dann könnte es sein dass mir warum
klingt ja dann immer eigentlich richtet
wurde manch einer deutschen schule
gezogen worden bin und es kritisch
hinterfragen das würde ich nicht nein
gesagt und jeden lehrer eltern und
seines kann meine die tatsache dass eine
bestimmte frage dass die nicht da jetzt
könnte sagen das ist prinzipiell denkbar
aber es reicht nicht dass deswegen
einfachen diesem sommer
11 sowie die tatsache dass bei dieser
frage erst durch frei aber deswegen
kannst dabei sein das ist meine antwort
wäre das wirklich kritisches
hinterfragen per se immer frei ist also
wenn wir jetzt nicht einfach nur so tun
ach ich hab da so zweifel und so also
die frage ist was wir unter kritisch
hinterfragen verstehen aber wenn wir
kritisch hinterfragen müssen verstehen
dass man etwas prüft und abwägt dann
kann ja jeder der kritisch hinterfragt
zu ganz anderen ergebnissen kommen
und deswegen glaube ich dass im begriff
des kritischen abwägen und selbst wenn
es sozial gefordert ist immer schon die
freiheit drin steckt also wer sich das
zum prinzip macht kritisch hinterfragen
der ist per se in meinen augen frei das
würde ich eben noch so könnte das nicht
auch einfach es gibt natürlich diese
chance gibt natürlich diese auffassung
dass man sich das zu so einer art seine
mode gemacht hat naja ich lasse es immer
die intellektuellen raushängen oder so
das ist für mich aber dann nicht
kritisch über die frage was man kritisch
versteht und da kritisch wirklich als
sowie immanuel kant ist meint nicht die
vernunft aufklärung also nachprüfen
vergleichen und sich eine eigene meinung
bilden unabhängig von der allgemeinen
meinung dann würde eben sagen denke
kritisch und wenn selbst wenn mir das an
eingetrichtert würde es wäre nichts
unfrei ist das wäre im grad der
imperativ der aufklärung geben die
größte freiheit ist sie es gibt aber sie
der frage wie man kritisch schätzt
verstehen
zwar denken
ich glaube dass das sich dem schiff
widersprechen würde ich glaube das wäre
ja genau ich glaube dass ein ksk es kann
kein kritischen chip geben wäre meine
these aber jetzt haben wir zwei meldung
erst dann da er
also genau dieses tränen wäre sozusagen
die negative freiheit immer die freiheit
von ich bin nicht abhängig von irgendwas
und dieser imperativ letztendlich der
kategorische imperativ dieser
eingetrichtert impetus zu kritisieren
der würde eben nur eine form sein sollen
anregungen der uns die uns in freiheit
setzen könnte
[Musik]
das ebenfalls dass die männchen oder
so kann die fähigkeiten ist aus meiner
auswahl prima in münchen aus meinen
wünschen ersten zurückzutreten renate
ihnen gegeben
dazu kamen bis zu setzen und das
überhaupt
sich sie genau also sich mal auch frei
zu machen wobei das sitzen wieder
zirkuläre wenn man dann sagt ich mache
mich frei weil dadurch werde erst durch
die koalition zweiter stufe frei wenn
ich jetzt aber die bildung von volition
zweiter ordnung wieder auf aus freiheit
erkläre dann begegnen zirkelschluss und
bisschen also das sind zirkuläre das
problem aber einfach mal dass man sagt
im schwachen sinne
ich muss mich einfach mal zurückziehen
können ich muss irgendwie immun sein
gegenüber so unmittelbar meinen willen
in ihren bestrebungen und regungen
da ist schon viel mit gewonnen ich
glaube das meint er auch hier mit dieser
bildung wie wir jetzt aber noch ein
bisschen genauer betrachten diese
meldung also die kommen glaube ich aus
meiner meinung nach berechtigt sehen
also ich dauernd davon irgendwann muss
macht folgendes team beispiel gegen
diesen willen 21 begriff machen das geht
genau in die richtung dass er will sein
stellen uns eine gesellschaft vor die
zwei klassen haben also in die reichen
und einflussreichen
einen seite und die klasse und die
gleichen menschen können irgendwie
system material der r-klasse manchmal
ergeben dass die einfluss nehmen können
auf alle auf alles war lange auf allen
positionen auf alle wünsche die menschen
in dieser klasse haben und zwar nicht
nur auf dem indischen erster sportler
auf die wünsche und position zwei
deutschland für unseren einsatz ist und
nehmen wir zum beispiel anders sie eben
also dass ärmere klasse haben alle auch
umsetzen manipulation den wunsch der
breiten klasse zu geben und sie haben
auf dem wunsch diesen wunsch zu haben
und so weiter
und wie würden sie sagen also das ist
ein paradebeispiel von jemanden der
unfreiheit und trotzdem scheint der alle
bedingungen zu erfüllen die man nach
frankfurt da fühlen muss man mindestens
und ich glaube das ist so ein bisschen
vielleicht aus dieser motivation heraus
na ja das andere so dass vielleicht das
noch nicht ausreicht wird dass wir ein
so dass die eigenen wünsche in einklang
zueinander stehen so dessen bruder punkt
da kann man noch drauf wir gute punkte
so an meinem hinterkopf haben diese
ganzen probleme die wir jetzt ansprechen
die tauchen immer wieder auf bei allen
weiteren zitaten
irgendwas gekauft oder nicht
es gibt hier eingebunden
im moment ist ungleich konsument und
weise
ich gehe
ja also sie haben jetzt einen guten
punkt gebracht dass ich sogar die
phänomenologie der freiheit stark
gemacht haben harry frankfurt ist kein
phänomenologie phänomenologie ist ein
philosoph eine philosophie die eben
versucht auch in der erscheinung also
wie sich zb ein mensch bewegt darin dann
auch irgendwie freiheit dingfest zu
machen und so eine perspektive die
phänomenologische perspektive nimmt er
in frankfurt nicht ein
er ist er sein kann diana er ist ein
starker rationalist kurz gesagt er
versteht sich als rational ist dagegen
gibt es eine position ist die
phänomenologie schreibt phänomenologie
die schaut eben konkret wird der name
schon sagt die phänomene und versucht
anhand der phänomene bestimmte
eigenschaften aufzuweisen und gerade in
das der freiheit ist es natürlich ein
riesending schiller sagt freiheit in der
erscheinung friedrich schiller ist das
ein großer denker gegen kann zum
beispiel auch wenn es um die ästhetik
geht ästhetisches phänomen
die fallen bei frankfurt zu aus dem
focus heraus dabei wären die
künstlerische behandlungen oder auch
spiel das spiel solche dinge gerade auch
besonderes ausgezeichnete phänomene der
freiheit also die frage ist auch immer
wo versuchen wir willensfreiheit
aufzuzeigen und frankfurt macht das eben
sehr häufig nur anhand der handlung und
des willens letztendlich aber kann man
nicht auch sagen der bewegung zum
beispiel und das wäre dann so eine
perspektive die ihr die phänomenologie
einnehmen würde also ein berechtigter
einwand dass wir immer auch schauen
müssen von welchem theoretischen rahmen
wir willensfreiheit behandeln oder
freiheit allgemein und helle frankfurt
ist eben ein ratssaal ist kurz gesagt
auch wenn er jetzt am ende sagen wird es
ist nicht die vernunft die für die
willensfreiheit entscheidend ist der
wille aber letztendlich ist ein
rationalist ja
[Musik]
die sich vor dem nicht unterstellen
welche möglichkeiten die wirte 2010
beeinflusst man zu manipulieren wollten
wenn sie erst mal daran
denn in dieser struktur hatten und die
will ich und das 1
sie sind können hier
und er stelle mich erst ging jetzt fünf
tage später
er ist ebenso die vierte anhalt sagt als
jemand das wilms verhilft ihm benannte
stunde lang lang zwischen seinen
positionen besteht und dann wäre es
irgend beispiel stellen uns ebenso einen
vor der manipulation gibt man einklang
sein wünschen hat das würden wir doch
sagen er ist nicht wenn zwei obwohl ist
ein plan hat und das wäre ein beispiel
und man muss vielleicht auch noch eine
sache berücksichtigen geht es jetzt nun
das faktische vorliegen des einklangs
oder geht es nicht vielmehr um das
herstellen dieses einklangs also und das
einstimmen einschwingen deshalb und wenn
wenn er nämlich sagt hier die bildung
dann ist eben dieses aktive moment und
nicht nur dieses effektive moment gibt
es jetzt aber auf dieses effektive
moment wie ist der wille beschaffen wie
liegt davor
und wenn er so vorliegt das eher
harmonisch ist dann ist es ein effekt
der willens verhalten ich habe jetzt
eher so ein bisschen meine leser hat
frank wird es eher die dass es eben auf
die bildung ankommt wie wird denn neben
der billa wille harmonisch gestaltet und
darin sehe ich ihr dann die freiheiten
für die befolgung ist dilemma auf machen
also entweder er meint damit frei
gebetet und dann könnte sie zog und dann
können es eben vorstellen dass das gehen
man das so manipuliert dass man es eben
dann selbst genau stimmt das stimm ich
dir zustimmen ich dazu aber als ich
glaube dass eben dieser dass wir das ein
bisschen noch stark machen müssen dieses
bildung das ist scheint mir das
entscheidende zu sein aber es stimmt ja
auch letztendlich zu diesen fällen die
man sich konstruieren kann dass man
dennoch nicht willensfreiheit vielleicht
vorliegen hatte weil ihm wichtig sondern
die die spontanität und die
urheberschaft nie so ganz im zentrum
steht von spontanität die spielt nicht
so eine grosse das browser guard ist
inkompatibel ist und das ist ja genau
ist was bringt auszuschalten sind franke
dann am ende sagen ist letztlich egal
woher diese position gekommen
die vielleicht sogar
die deponien sind vielleicht durch
andere sammeln und das ist genau der
stein des anstoßes für den komplettesten
wie vernehmbaren gesagt mein genau
solchen beispiel sehen wir doch dass es
dann noch etwas entscheidendes unserem
compose und zwar das siegel nicht
irgendwie von außen irgendwie
determiniert ist dass sich die
so widmen sondern diese farbkombination
ohne diese selbst gegenüber schlafen
erste staffel bewirbt muss man irgendwie
noch dazu denken also das ist doch genau
diese edition
ich weiß jetzt auch noch nicht wir
lassen uns einfach mal überraschen
vielleicht noch eine letzte kurze
meldung dann müssen nämlich weitergehen
die zeit ist schon vorangeschritten
[Musik]
essen
getagt ich kann noch auf die wünsche
zweite stufe
[Musik]
genau das ist das regress problem was
wir in den leitfragen auch kurz
angesprochen hatten wir kommen da noch
darauf zu sprechen das ist aber ein
generelles problem was hier schon
angelegt ist nämlich warum sollte ich
nicht nur eine höhere stufe dann
brauchen und das ist vielleicht aber
auch noch ein guter hinweis auf unseres
probelauf unser problem dass das ja
alles determiniert rede terminiert sein
könnte weil frankfurt ein argument warum
es reicht dass es meine zweite stufe
endet ich glaube sein argument dafür
dass es hier mit ausreichend ist bringt
uns wieder argumente für dieses
determinismus problem was beta von in
vagen gezeigt hat wir kommen jetzt noch
drauf deswegen würde ich sagen wir reden
jetzt mal da ist noch nicht drüber aber
kommen gleich wieder zurück war jetzt
möchte das nächste zitat vorlesen ein
bisschen das war ein bisschen weiter
jetzt durchkommen sagt also nur wenn der
satz auf die zweite art und das wort
villa in den besonderen sinn der
vorschlag gebraucht werden dann
beschreibt der satz
haas will den willen eines handelnden zu
beschreiben heißt entweder den wunsch
oder die wünsche an zu geben die ihn zu
den handlungen bewegen die er
tatsächlich ausführt oder heißt den
wunsch und die wünsche anzuführen die
ihn bewegen werden wenn er handelt oder
die ihn bewegen würden falls er handelte
der wille eines handelnden ist als
identisch mit einem oder mehreren seiner
wünsche die es der stufe aber der
begriff des willens wie ich ihn
gebraucht ist nicht umfangs gleich mit
dem begriff von etwas das den handel
bloß bis zu einem gewissen grade geneigt
macht auch in kliniken bestimmter weise
zu handeln sondern es ist der begriff
eines effektiven oder handlungs
wirksamen wunsch lässt ist eine ganz
wichtige unterscheidung zwischen wille
und wunsch der eine person dazu bringt
oder dazu bringen wird oder wurde den
ganzen weg bis zu einer handlung zu
geben also ist der begriff des willens
auch nicht anfangs gleich mit dem
begriff dessen was jemand zu tun
beabsichtigt wir haben jetzt viele
wurden schon absicht das müssen wir
fallen soll sich voneinander
unterscheiden und obwohl jemand ganz
hess die absicht haben kann nix zu tun
so kann es doch sein dass er nichts
desto weniger etwas anderes statt dessen
tod weil sich trotz seiner absicht der
wunsch zu tun als schwächer oder weniger
effektiv erweist als ein anderer wieder
streiten der wunsch können sie jetzt
noch mal kurz sagen was der unterschied
zwischen den willen und den wunsch ist
was kommt beim willen noch hinzu was
beim wunsch nicht verhandelt
hier wurden betrieben um einen baum
die haare den pfeilern
ich glaube dass sie meinen das richtige
als er mir scheint dass hier das
effektive behandlung wirksame das
entscheidend ist also ein wunsch der
handlungs wirksam werden möchte und der
eben wo das subjekt bereit ist alle
schritte zu gehen
er sagt den ganzen weg bis zu einer
handlung zu gehen also handlungs wirksam
viele wünsche ich wünsche gerne das und
ich wünsche gerne dass das ist die kälte
existieren
es können auch verschiedene ist können
auch wünsche koexistieren die sich
direkt widersprechen
dann habe ich vielleicht in mir zu
sprechen der wünsche also einmal meine
jetzt irgendwie einzuhalten gerecht zu
werden die gar nicht so toll
und wenn ich jetzt natürlich essen sie
sofort dann ist es falsch zu sagen dass
mein wunsch die diät einzuhalten auch
mein wille ist die technologie weit
dieser wunsch die handlungs wirksam
also genau ihr können die wünsche
erfüllt habe was genau als wille gleich
handlungs wirksam handlungs effektiver
wunsch ja das sagt das hier und heute in
essen wollte mich eigentlich einen geld
machen
dann zeige ich ja endlich gold für die
ganze zeit wenn die entnahmen kann
nämlich sagen wir nehmen wenn sie
trocken ist
die anderes wirksamkeit ist dabei
indikator dafür
zumindest der verdacht dass ich versucht
mein bruder punkt ist dann auch dieses
konkreten effektiver konkreter weil wenn
ich jetzt dann auch auf die handlung
abziele vom bloßen wunsch dann heißt es
dass der wunsch sich auch einer
instrumentellen vernunft bedienen muss
er muss konkret werden wie will ich denn
genau das scheint mir auch noch ein
unterschied des willens zum wunsch zu
sein der wunsch kann sehr vage seien
ich möchte gerne dass der wille muss
immer ganz genau dann angeben sag jetzt
mal wie das auch dann umgesetzt wird
diese instrumentelle reflexion muss zum
wunsch noch hinzukommen damit es ein
witz sein kann oder und die tatsache
dass auch dann vielleicht genau
irgendwann halt
bist du in video das die sache eben auch
sonst ist das vielleicht einfach nur
wünschen sind nicht bereit die politik
soll greifen und verleiht dem kinobesuch
ist segen und stattdessen hat sich von
den 800 zu schreiben das musst du an
lässt diese also immerhin der
natürlichen halbzeit sprachen sie
schreiben wir nicht so genau
also wir sagen auch wollten so ein
mögliches und wünschen zu allen
möglichen aber philosophisch kanada hat
auch ein bisschen strenger es ist ganz
wenig anstrengend zu machen aber es
scheint doch irgendwas dran zu sein wenn
sie unterscheidung und versucht es eben
mit dem er sagt man könnte auch sagen zu
der wunsch ist nur so eine art oder über
begriffen allgemein begriff und der
wille ist ist eines pcs oder sogar
konkret das individuum was unter diesen
generellen allgemeinen begriff fällt als
hier wird was wirklich subsumiert wird
individualisiert während der wunsch
einfach nur so generell ist könnte man
auch sagen hier wird wirklich konkret
ein konkreter fall unter 1 allgemeinen
wunsch gebracht und dieses
konkretisieren diese instanz ihren des
wunsches das wäre der wille
naja
also wichtige unterscheidung zwischen
wille und wunsch das ist aber auch schon
bei immanuel kant zu also das ist eine
ganz kanzian ische unterscheidung das
finden sie bei kann jemand hat einen
wunsch zweiter stufe wenn er entweder
einfach einen bestimmten wunsch haben
möchte oder wenn er möchte dass ein
bestimmter wunsch sein will es sei für
diesen zweiten fall will ich die wünsche
der zweiten stufe koalitionen zweiter
stufe nennen
nun glaube ich dass es für das person
seien wesentlich ist position zweiter
stufe und nicht ganz allgemein wünsche
zweiter stufe zu haben es ist logisch
möglich wenn auch unwahrscheinlich dass
ein handelnder wohl wünsche zweiter
stufe aber keine koalition in der
zweiten stufe hat ein solches wesen das
alterwürdige zweiter stufe aber keine
koalition der zweiten stufe hat wäre in
meinen augen keine person als einen
triebhaften englisch ponton bezeichne
ich jemanden der wünsche erste stufe hat
aber deshalb keine person ist weil er
gleichgültig ob er wünsche der zweiten
stufe bis jetzt keine koalition zweiter
stufe hat jetzt noch mal sehr
kompliziert formuliert was ist jetzt
bitteschön ein ponton können sie das
nochmal hier so ein bisschen re
formulieren das ist ein wichtiger
begriff
ja ich wünsche aber diese wünsche haben
hat mich effektiven kann ich nicht
diesen diesem wunsch nach nachhaltige
wissen also das bringt mich auch dass er
verstehen beschreibt dann aber eher
nicht in diese zweite schule und den
wunsch zu behandeln
ja es war noch mal gerade die
entscheidende passage es ist logisch
möglichen auch unwahrscheinlich dass ein
handelnder wohl wünsche zweiter stufe
also der wand an hat wünsche zweiter
stufe aber keine koalitionen der zweiten
stufe hat als er hat hole wünsche
zweiter stufe
aber er möchte sie nicht handlungs
wirksam werden lassen
das ist das entscheidende doch noch eine
meldung dazu
das wäre eine möglichkeit habe ich
glaube frankfurt denkt den vermarkter
korrigiert mistkerl korrigiert nicht
dass es möglich wäre aber es eben gerade
nicht gemacht wird oder wie siehst du
siehst du es also jedenfalls sind die
wünsche zweiter stufe vorhandener bahn
am montag wünsche zum beispiel gern als
beispiel wo ich meine ich wäre so ein
kalter menschen
ich würde mir wünschen dass ich wenn an
ein rot ist in wunsch verspüren zu
helfen dann habe ich einen wunsch hatte
stufe ich wünsche mir es wünschen in dem
komischen zu haben diese menschen helfen
aber in den jahren nicht auf den geist
das ist vielleicht ein bettler und ich
will aber nicht gelten natürlich schon
ihren dann wünsche ich mir vielleicht
den wunsch zu helfen
aber ich habe nicht auch noch die
position zweite stufe dass ich wünsche
mir nicht dass ich immer hin
weil das würde bedeuten dass ich da
wirklich noch geld gibt und in
müncheberg dieser unterschied regel hier
haben zwischen wünschen zweiter schuss
und
funktionsweise wünschte zwei richtungs
erwünscht ist sich auf meine wünsche
reichen und position zweiter punkt wir
sind wünsche die sich auf meine herrn
bewusst entschieden dass ich wünsche mir
einen bestimmten handlung zuwachs an
grund aber das ist ja nicht ich wünsche
mir nicht mehr wieder etwas abstrakt zu
wünschen dass ich hier zählt nicht ob
ich wünsche mir dass ich diesen
botschaft dass sie aufgrund dieses
wunsch danach etwas tun
also da geht es wirklich um das was dann
auch wirklich am ende
aufgrund meiner wünsche getan oder nicht
getan und eine million trieb abstimmung
mit seinen worten wäre eben einem lesen
bis zugleich wünschte zweiter stufe hat
also das schließt freilich aus also
vielleicht wünscht bestimmte wünsche
waren okay aber das ist auf alle fälle
ein wesentliches teilstück der zug aus
angst um seinen kopf
ich wünsche mir nicht als praktisch
einwohnern wäre ein wesen was wünsche
zweiter stufe hat die nicht
handlungswillig sahm werden müssen ja
genau also
das wäre ein sehr seltener fahren aber
es ist logisch ist logisch möglich das
ist auch typisch für harry frankfurt
immer zu sagen es ist trotzdem denkbar
es ist logisch möglich wenn auch
unwahrscheinlich
wobei mich jetzt hier da so ein bisschen
irritiert da sagt ein handeln da weil er
kommt ja eigentlich das handlungs
wirksame dann ich weiß nicht was er
damit meint dann handeln aus dem
handlungs frei wäre ja richtig
die verteilung dieser kann aber einen
wunsch natürlich sich bilden und
wunschgemäß
also könnte sich vielleicht auch eine
meinung bilden als ein wunsch ebenfalls
der aber nicht aber nicht halt irgendwie
dass diese meinung der sich darüber
bildet das die es ihm eigentlich völlig
egal weil sie nämlich nicht zur handlung
führen muss oder gar nicht führen kann
bei ihm ja weil sie nicht eher macht
sich da also tolle reflexionen es wäre
praktisch ein willens frei der aber nur
handlungsfreiheit ist könnte man sagen
einer der ein handlungsfreiheit plus
also an handlungsfreiheit wesen war es
noch diese ganzen reflexion hat aber die
nicht nutzt letztendlich also einen an
handlungsfreiheit plus sozusagen also
erkrankt genau jetzt haben mehrere
meldungen erst hier
visionen zweite stufe
das problem wird als flucht gelungen
neben im ganzen spiel das dann zu werden
ich glaube noch nicht dass das das jetzt
eine lösung ist er kommt jetzt noch auf
die lösung gleich zu sprechen hier ist
immer noch in der regress problematik
treten warum könnte man nicht nur ein
drittel dritte stufe usw ausbilden
müssen um willens frei zu sein also das
ist jetzt noch nicht die die antwort auf
diese lösung des problems
missionieren nur eines sagen
wie kann man unterscheiden ich denke es
ist ähnlich wie im vorjahr gesprochen
das ist noch mal um sich im land
erreichte ende des aufsatzes ist auch
gemüse wie tomaten schauen oder verdeckt
dann freilich zieht sich aus können wir
vielleicht über den termin zu sein
anfragen zu haben oder nicht er scheint
da dem eher positiv zu gewinnen ein
bisschen gedanken und wir scheinen
dadurch bis geben
zweifel zu haben und es wirklich schon
ausreicht werden bilden
aber ja ich habe das geht auch einen
ähnlichen punkt oder genau noch eine
meldung da müssen wir weitermachen
diesen zustand
man kann gerade im kino falsch geparkt
haben
st
ich würde mich ein teil
es war der erste er kann es und das ja
meint an ehrlich sein ich bin nur genau
in dem moment eine person wenn ich so
eine position zweiter schock für
arbeiten mit meinem wunsch
übereinstimmen
das ganz ehrlich sein das heißt ich
werde nur bestimmten ausschnitt meines
lebens mit person
ich glaube er meint es eher so das
gemeinwesen bisher immer wieder mal
willensfreiheit aus als wären sogar nord
und wer dann vielleicht etwas ein wesen
das nie
immerhin sind also das heißt es wäre
nicht so wenn wir dann im takt raum
haben und da unsere unverbindlichen
wünsche die wir auch niemandem erzählen
wollen da so nachgeben
dass wir in dem moment einfach versionen
sind sondern macht und man hat also so
müssen klingt es also so genau behandelt
er diese frage nicht bedenklich besser
gewesen wäre
vermögen so ein vermögen anzusetzen oder
dass er seine person ist ein wesen was
das vermögen hat eben wo dazu ein
zweiter stufe auszubilden die handlungs
wirksam werden können einwohnern hätte
dieses vermögen gar nicht dass handlungs
wirksam
also ich denke es ist er damit in diese
komische einsicht kommen dass wir dann
ganz kurzen moment so ist dann wäre es
mir total konter intuitiv zu sagen der
person begriff verträgen die normative
weil dann würde das heißen nur in dem
moment wo wir zwei hatten haben wir zum
beispiel auch ein recht auf leben und zu
weit wenn wir eingeschlafen das leben
der sims 3 wird und dann sofort das war
keine personen das kannst dich sein aber
andererseits wenn er es wirklich nur um
die fähig oder wie man das vermögen
vermögen hier dann ist wiederum die
frage ob das dann noch so klar ist der
schönste mehrere menschen aus herkommer
uns dann darauf zu sprechen sondern ist
und dadurch dann die fragen ist es dann
so klar dass kleinkinder dieses vermögen
nicht ja das ist eine sprache ist
bereich dass in dieser position zweiter
spiel für mich haben am anfang aber wenn
wir sagen also dass tatsächlich
vorhanden sein sondern kann natürlich
nicht das entscheidende sondern höchst
es das ist eine spannung
genau und jetzt bringen und zentrales
zitat er sagt ein bisschen weiter auf
seite 73 wenn ich nun behauptet dass das
wesentliche im moment des person science
nicht der vernunft im willen liegt also
es eher ein wohl und er ist sozusagen so
will ich damit natürlich nicht
unterstellen das anwesen ohne vernunft
eine person sein kann denn allein dank
ihrer vernunft ist eine person fähig
sich die ihres eigenen willens kritisch
bewusst zu werden haben wir das
kritische und volition zweiter stufen zu
bilden daher setzt die willens struktur
einer person voraus dass sie ein
vernünftiges wesen ist also vernunft ist
sagen ist notwendig aber noch nicht
hinreichend willensfreiheit und jetzt
will ich einmal noch kurz begehen das
nächste mal noch mal kurz ein
also hier noch ein zitat wenn eine
person handeln dann leitet sie entweder
der wille den sie haben möchte oder ein
wille den silos seien
in einer triebhaft handelt dann das ist
ein kaltes worten dann keines von beiden
ja das gut muss verkehren und jetzt
gehen wir noch ganz kurz am schluss
würde ich sagen auf die handlungs
willensfreiheit ein dass auch noch
wichtig erscheint mir nahe liegen und
auch nützlich die frage ob jemand einen
freien willen hat möglichst genau in
analogie zu der frage zu konstruieren ob
jemand willensfreiheit genießt nun ist
handlungsfreiheit jedenfalls im groben
umrisse die freiheit zu tun was man tun
möchte das haben wir schon besprochen
entsprechend besagt die behauptung dass
jemand sich eines freien willens erfreut
ebenfalls grob umrissen dass er frei ist
zu wollen was er wollen möchte also
wollen was man will
genauer heißt das dass er frei ist den
willen zu haben dinge haben möchte
genauso wie die frage nach der freiheit
eine handlung darauf zielt ob sie auch
die handlung ist die der betreffende
ausführen möchte
so bezieht sich die frage nach der
willensfreiheit darauf ob der wille den
eine hat der wille ist in haben möchte
das ist eine ganz analoge bestimmung
zwischen willen zu halten handeln
bemerkungen bezogen dass jetzt diese
dieser klasse wie denen man probiert es
vielleicht hatten
und hier kommt jetzt diese sicherstellen
nächste zitat jemand macht also dann von
seiner willensfreiheit gebraucht wird er
sicher steht dass sein wille und seine
position zweiter stufe 1 stimmen könnte
nicht dieses sicherstellen auch in
deinem beispiel bedeuten dass er
sicherstellt dass auch die koalition
nicht nur von außen induziert sind sie
fragen ist es etwas was innerhalb sagen
dass die große frage
praktisch ich nehme das jetzt mal hier
v1 und v2 interessiert nur dass hier
oder interessiert auch dass hier was
dazu geführt hat dass sieht ihn nur
dieses setting der vorliegenden volition
oder wünsche oder interessiert ihn auch
noch die herkunft des ganzen das
sicherstellen so lesen dass man
unabhängig
ein oder andere ursachen ich mache jetzt
ganz stark diese sicher stehen aber
trifft glaube ich betrifft glaube ich
nur diese diese einstimmung und nicht
die aus äußeren bedingungen das habe ich
jetzt nur so noch eingebracht und ein
bisschen stärker zu machen
aber ja
von uns messen an der einstellung
gute frage
offensichtlich nicht also baykal oder
jedenfalls nicht im sinne des das
moralisch vernünftig also bei immanuel
kant ist es so der sagt wir sind nur
dann frei wenn wir volition zweiter
stufe auf basis moralische überzeugungen
entwickeln
das ist eine gute frage also ich denke
mal vernunft muss jetzt nicht heißen bei
harris frankfurt das ist jetzt
vernünftig ist im sinne des das streng
logischen oder auch das streng
moralischen wir können uns nachher in
frankfurt zu wenn ich ihn richtig
verstehe auch koalition zweiter stufe
bilden die jetzt eben tendenziell
unvernünftig sind die eben unserem
unserer persönlichkeit ausdruck
verleihen
wir müssen zwar zur bildung gekommen
seien durch den einsatz von vernunft
aber sonst würde es ja auch heißen dass
wir nur dann ganz frei sind wenn wir
maximal rational handeln oder wenn wir
nur den fern und gesetzen unterliegen
als ich glaube es muss einfach eine
koalition gebildet werden
deren bildung sich dem gebrauchte
vernunft verdammt aber die selbst von
ihrem status her jetzt nicht rein
rational sein muss dass ich glaube es
ist einfach der weg wie wir hinkommen zu
der munition und wie siehst du es mit
dem status muss diese schwierigkeiten
erkannt
gewiss diese munition zweiter stiefel
auch wirklich die beste und vernünftig
so munition in dem slum hand sein muss
dann scheint es irgendwie nicht dankbar
zu sein dass wir dann auch frei sind
wenn wir etwas böses
und genau das tun und das ist natürlich
eine große schwierigkeit nichts
irgendwie böse
es muss nicht eine rein rationale
position sein sie muss nur mittels
rationalität gebildet worden sei
entscheidend ist der franck wird der
wille der wille ist immer noch wichtiger
als die vernunft
es muss als ein individueller willens
ausdruck sein eine eine koalition die
mit meiner persönlichkeit mit meiner
individualität sehr intim zusammenhängt
und es muss jetzt nicht ein perfekt
rationaler willens sein
das ist doch die sich danach selbst
es dürften aus dem unternehmen
das große abzusagen
oder
es ist eben nicht so dass die vernunft
als akteur gedacht wird bei harry
frankfurt sondern schon die person die
die vernunft gebraucht als es immer ein
wesentlicher gebrauchte vernunft als
seine erkenntnis und interesse ich
gebrauche die vernunft aus allen
bestimmten interesse persönlichen
interesse heraus aber entscheidend ist
wie ich glaube ich dass die vernunft
gebraucht wird und und der akteur der
willensbildung ist eben die person und
ich die vernunft ist und auch nicht der
wille sozusagen aber man spricht eben
häufig so wie sie richtig sagen ich dass
die vernunft etwas tut aber das wäre für
frankfurt eine personifikation gefallen
ist als es die person die die vernunft
gebraucht die sich der von uns bedient
um ihre koalition zu bilden und darin
kann sie ihre individualität zeigen oder
wie siehst du es mag auf alle fälle ist
es ganz wichtig dass man da nicht das
ist so eine tendenz die mannschaft kann
das
zumindest an der textliche dass die
vernunft südostasiens zu einer eigenen
identität sondern es ist da schon also
der verein verzichtet die person aber
ich glaube dass eine schwierigkeit
verborgen also das ist eine ganz
unschuldig wird der bau müsse natürlich
sagen okay aber muss ich nicht aufregend
wie man also die ganze handlung der mann
der aus kommen scheint mir vernünftig zu
sein wenn ich noch vernünftig
überlegungen gemacht hat über die
position zweiter stufe
und da scheint ein regress gekommen weil
dann müsste ich nochmal die position
zweite stufe hinterfragen und dann
kommen wir an die dritte irgendwas ist
die frage ist ob sie mich vielleicht
manchmal vernünftig sein kann die
vernunft auszuschalten
und das ist auch glaube ich ein gutes
schlusswort die mannschaft jetzt
auszuschalten weil wir eben leider schon
über derzeit darüber sind sie sehen wir
sind noch nicht durchgekommen müssen den
nächsten sitzung noch einmal zurückkommt
vor allem auf dieses regress problem und
lesen dann aber in der zweiten hälfte
text von peter pan in welden oder doch
ein von frankfurt genau den über
alternative möglichkeiten mit denen auch
mit ok also dann bis zur nächsten
sitzung